>> Tucker: OH, THE FREE STATE
OF FLORIDA HERE FOR THE PATRIOT
AWARDS.
A HIGHLIGHT OF THE YEAR.
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
THE COLLAPSE OF THE CRYPTO
CURRENCY EXCHANGE FTX IS, EVEN
IF YOU'RE NOT INTERESTED IN
CRYPTOCURRENCY, A HISTORY
CHANGING EVENT.
IT MAY TURN OUT TO BE THE
BIGGEST SINGLE DAY LOSS OF
ASSETS IN THE HISTORY OF MONEY.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVAPORATED
IN MOMENTS AND IT'S NOT CLEAR
WHAT HAPPENED TO A LOT OF THE
MONEY.
IT JUST DISAPPEARED AND AS IT
DID, IT SPARK ADD GROWING
FINANCIAL CRISIS ACROSS THE
ENTIRE SECTOR OF THE ECONOMY.
DISASTER THAT QUITE POSSIBLY
COULD GET VERY WORSE, VERY SOON.
BUT THE STORY OF FTX IMPLOSION
IS BIGGER THAN EVEN IN THE
GLOBAL RECESSION IT MAY CAUSE.
IT IS THE STORY OF THE COMPLETE
AND UTTER CORRUPTION OF THE
PEOPLE THAT RUN OUR COUNTRY.
THE VERY PEOPLE WHO SHOULD HAVE
BEEN COVERING AND REGULATING AND
REIGNING FTX AND THE 30-YEAR-OLD
FOUNDER WERE PROFITING FROM THE
SCAM.
NOT JUST A FEW BUT NEARLY ALL OF
THEM FROM THE NEWS MEDIA, PAID
OFF BY SAM BANKMAN-FRIED TO
LEADERSHIP OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY ALSO PAID OFF BY SAM
BANKMAN-FRIED TO THE CHAIRMAN OF
SECURITIES AND EXCHANGE
COMMISSION, THE SCC COMMISSIONER
HIMSELF GARY GENSLER.
THEY ALL KNEW THAT FTX WAS NOT A
REAL COMPANY.
AND SAM BANKMAN-FRIED WAS A
FRAUD.
IF THEY DIDN'T KNOW THAT, THEY
CERTAINLY SHOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT
BECAUSE IT WAS VERY OBVIOUS TO
ANYONE THAT BOTHERED TO PAY
ATTENTION.
ONE OF THE FEW WHO DID PAY
ATTENTION WAS A SHORT SELLER
CALLED MARK CAHOTIS WHO TOOK ONE
LOOK AT SAM BANKMAN-FRIED, SBF
FOR SHORT, AND RECOGNIZED HERE
IS A CON ARTIST.
OBVIOUSLY.
WATCH THIS TAPE THAT AIRD.
>> SBF AND THE ACCOUNT FOR SBF
IS BAILING OUT KNOWN PONZ IS AND
FRAUDS IN THE CRYPTO SPACE.
EVERYONE THAT'S GONE BANKRUPT OR
IS A PROVEN FRAUD BUT NOTHING
HERE FITS.
EVERYONE, EVERYTHING READS LIKE
THIS THING IS A COMPLETE SCAM.
AND I THINK THIS THING IS DIRTY
AND ROTTEN TO THE CORE.
>> Tucker: SO IF THAT GUY ON A
SMALL AUDIENCE INVESTMENT
CHANNEL CAN SEE FRAUD, WHERE WAS
GARY GENSLER OF THE SEC?
BY THE WAY THE TELL IN THE
SENTENCE YOU HEARD IS THAT SAM
BANKMAN-FRIED COULDN'T EXPLAIN
WHERE HE GOT HIS MONEY.
HERE YOU ARE A 30-YEAR-OLD
BILLIONAIRE.
HOW'D YOU DO THAT?
IF YOU CAN'T TELL US, MAYBE
THAT'S A RED FLAG AND THINK MOST
INVESTORS WOULD HAVE RECOGNIZED
IT.
FOR THE MOST PART, THEY DIDN'T.
NOR DO THEY SEEM TO KNOW THE
OBVIOUS AND CONFIDENT SAM
BANKMAN-FRIED'S CAROLINE
ELLISON.
SHE WAS TOTALLY AND UNQUALIFIED
FOR THE JOB SHE CLAIMED TO HAVE.
SHE HAD NO TRACK RECORD OF
SUCCESS AT ANYTHING AND REPORTLY
WENT ONLINE AND THEN ON THE
PODCAST BACK IN MAY, MONTHS
BEFORE THE COLLAPSE, CAROLINE
ELLISON CAME OUT AND ADMITTED
SHE HAD NO IDEA WHAT SHE WAS
DOING.
WATCH THIS.
>> DO YOU THINK YOU'VE BEEN ABLE
TO PULL THIS THING OFF WITHOUT
YOUR MATHEMATICS DEGREE OR IT
HAS BEEN THE PILLAR OF YOUR
TRADING ACTIVITY?
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY COULD PULL
IT OFF WITHOUT MY MATH DEGREE.
USE VERY LITTLE MATH.
STARTING OUT AS AN INTERN AND
YOU, YOU KNOW, DO SOMETHING AND
ACCIDENTLY LOSE MAYBE $1,000 AT
YOUR DECEMBERING, YOU'RE LIKE O,
EVERYONE IS GOING TO HATE ME NOW
AND IT'S TERRIBLE.
OVERTIME YOU HAVE TO -- OVER
TIME YOU HAVE TO GET COMFORTABLE
WITH LARGER AND LARGER SWINGS OF
MONEY.
YEAH, TRYING TO THINK OF A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF A TRADE WHERE I'VE
LOST A TON OF MONEY.
WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
I PROBABLY DON'T WANT TO GO INTO
SPECIFICS TOO MUCH ABOUT THAT.
>> Tucker: I'VE LOST A TON OF
MONEY.
NO BIG DEAL.
IT'S NOT MINE AND I KNOW THERE'S
NO MATH HERE AT THE
CRYPTOCURRENCY EXCHANGE.
LET'S SEND HER BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
LOST A LOT OF MONEY, MONEY THAT
INVESTORS INCLUDING
INSTITUTIONAL INVESTORS AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HOPING TO
RETIRE WITH THE MONEY ALL GONE
BECAUSE WE DON'T DO MATH.
IT'S SO OUTDATED.
HERE'S THE AMAZING THING, NONE
OF THIS SEEMED TO PHASE THE
BIGGEST INSTITUTIONAL INVESTORS.
SEQUOIA, THEIR ENTIRE JOB IS TO
ACCESSORIESING.
IT WASN'T REALLY ABOUT RISK AND
REWARD.
IT WAS ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE.
EARLIER THIS YEAR, MICHAEL
GRIMES, A FORMER SPOKESPERSON
FOR BILL CLINTON SEEMED TO BE
MAKING AN AWFUL AMOUNT OF MONEY
IN THE FINANCE WORD AND
APPROACHED ELON MUSK WITH AN
OFFER ON BEHALF OF SBF.
HE WANTS YOU TO INVEST.
ELON MUSK DIDN'T GET TO BE THE
RICHEST ON THE PLANET BY
INVESTING IN THINGS LIKE THAT
AND HE APPARENTLY SMELLED BS AND
TURNED GRIMES DOWN.
IN THEIR EXCHANGE, WHICH HAS
SINCE BECOME PUBLIC, GRIMES
MULTIPLE TIMES TOLD MUSK THAT BY
THE WAY, SAM BANKMAN-FRIED IS A
HUGE DONOR TO THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
"MAJOR DEMOCRATIC DONOR" GRIMES
WROTE TO MUSK.
SECOND TO BLOOMBURG IN THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN.
WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO DO WITH
THE INVESTMENT?
THAT SHOULD BE IRRELEVANT BUT
WAS SUBSEQUENT TO THE PITCH.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A HYBRID OF
SOME KIND AND NOT IN A
REASSURING WAY.
SOME WAS HAPPENING IN SECRET BUT
A LOT WAS HAPPENING IN PUBLIC IN
FRONT OF THE NEWS MEDIA.
OF COURSE A LOT OF THEM KNEW SAM
BANKMAN-FRIED BECAUSE HE WAS
SENDING A LOT OF THE THEM AND
WHEN HE WASN'T, HE WAS DESPERATE
FOR THE PUBLICITY COULD PROVIDE
AND HE WAS ON MORE MAGAZINES
THAN MADONNA AND SHOULD BE HAVE
BEEN ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS
BUSINESS BUT THEY DIDN'T.
THEY PROMOTED HIM.
>> CALL HIM THE JP MORGAN OF
CRYPTO; RIGHT.
JOWSKI YEAH, THE MICHAEL JORDAN
OF CRYPTO IF YOU WILL.
>> WHY SHOULD WE CARE ABOUT A
FLOPPY HAIRED VEGAN FIDGET
SPINNING CRYPTOBILLIONAIRE THAT
SLEEPS ON A BEAN BAG CHAIR
DURING THE SO CALLED CRYPTO
WINTER.
THE 30-YEAR-OLD CEO HAS BEEN
REFERRED TO AS CRYPTO'S WHITE
KNIGHT.
>> JP MORGAN OF THIS GENERATION,
SAM BANKMAN-FRIED'S FTX.
IS HE THE JP MORGAN OR WARREN
BUFFET?
>> IT'S YET TO BE DETERMINED?
>> IS HE VANDERBILT?
>> HE CAN BE.
>> IS HE A CREDIT SCANDAL?
>> IS HE CARNEGIE?
>> IF HE GIVES A LOT OF
LIBRARIES HE IS.
>> Tucker: HE'S THE JP MORGAN
OF FINANCE, OF CRYPTO.
HE'S THE MICHAEL JORDAN OF
CRYPTO.
WAIT A SECOND, MICHAEL JORDAN IS
NOT IN CRYPTO.
HE PLAYED BASKETBALL.
WELL, SAM BANKMAN-FRIED IS NOT
REALLY IN CRYPTO EITHER.
HOW WE ALL GETTING RICH THE JP
MORGAN HE'LL BE A TRILLION
THEIR.
WHY WERE ALL THESE PEOPLE
PUSHING A SCAM THAT ANY NORMAL
PERSON, EVEN A PERSON WITH NO
BACKGROUND IN FINANCE AND SORT
OF AN ELEMENTARY UNDERSTANDING
OF PROFIT LOSS EQUATIONS COULD
HAVE SEEN AND COULD COLLAPSE IN
THE MEND.
END.
HE PLAYS A ROLE AND THE HERD
INSTINCT.
WHO IS BENEFITING FROM ALL THIS?
WE KNOW THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
BENEFITED AND SAM BANKMAN-FRIED
DONATED $40 MILLION TO DEMOCRATS
TO THE PSYCHOAND WILL LARGER
THAN ANY DEMOCRAT APART FROM
SOROS AND THEN $1 BILLION FOR
THE NEXT ELECTION.
THAT'S DEMOCRACY.
HE WASN'T DOING IT IN PRIVATE
AND BRAGGING ABOUT IT AND THEN
GOING ON IN PUBLIC ABOUT HOW
POLITICIANS, DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIANS WERE BEGGING HIM FOR
MONEY.
WATCH THIS.
>> HOW DO YOU FIND POLITICAL
FUNDRAISERS?
THEY COME TO YOU AND WHAT TYPE
OF CANDIDATES DO YOU SUPPORT?
>> IF I PULMOD OUT MY PHONE AND
LOOKED AT LAST TEN TEXT
MESSAGES, ABOUT HALF WILL BE
PEOPLE ASKING FOR, YOU KNOW,
POLITICIANS ASKING FOR
CONTRIBUTIONS.
>> Tucker: SO WHY WERE YOU
TELLING US THIS IN PUBLIC?
BY THE WAY, IF YOU'RE SHAKING
LIKE A NAKED MAN IN A SNOWSTORM
IN THE MIDDLE OF AN INTERVIEW,
MAYBE THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG
WITH YOU.
SEND THAT BOY ANOTHER BILLION
DOLLARS.
SO HOW SUBSTANTIAL ARE WE
OVERSTATING THIS?
MAKING PARTISAN POINTS AND
THINGS COLLAPSED AND CLEARLY A
PONZI ARE AND ARE WE TRYING TO
ATTACK THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY NOW?
NO, IT'S ACTUALLY JUSTIFIED.
THIS GUY WAS A MAJOR DONOR.
MAJOR DONOR.
ACCORDING TO TO HEAD OF CITADEL,
DEFEATING DONALD TRUMP WAS
LITERALLY ON THE BALANCE SHEET
OF FTX.
WATCH THIS.
>> FTX CROSSES INTO A ZONE THAT
ALL OF US ARE WORRIED ABOUT.
ON THE BALANCE SHEET, FTX HAS A
LINE CALMED TRUMP LOSE.
AND SAM WAS THE SECOND BIGGEST
DONOR TO DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES.
>> I'M GOING TO LEAVE IT TO
EVERYBODY ELSE TO DRAW THEIR OWN
CONCLUSIONS ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING HERE.
>> Tucker: ANOTHER REPORTER
SAYS WE'RE OUT OF TIME AND CAN'T
GO TOO DEEPLY INTO THAT.
REALLY?
LET'S GO MORE DEEPLY.
IT'S INTERESTING.
POLITICIANS LOVE THE GUY AND HE
WAS A CASH SPIGOT AND THAT'S
WHAT HIGHWAY WANT THE MOST.
WHERE'S THE REGULATORS AND
THERE'S A GOVERNMENT THAT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE INDEPENDENT OF
OFFICE HOLDERS AND REGULATORY
STATE THAT KEEPS UPON SITUATIONS
FROM HAPPENING AND WHERE WERE
THEY?
THEN HE POSED FOR A PICTURE WITH
MAXINE WATERS AND A HEAD
FINANCIAL IN THE CONGRESS AND
THEN THE HOMETOWN NEWSPAPER OF
GOVERNMENT DID NO REPORTING ON
THE ACTUAL BUSINESS.
THEY JUST WROTE A PUFF PIECE
ABOUT HOW COOL IS IT THAT THE
GUY WITH FUNKY HAIR CAN'T SIT
STILL AND SLEEPS ON A BEAN BAG
IS GETTING SUPER RICH?
HOW DO HE PULL THIS SCAM?
HOW DID HE DO THAT?
WELL, WITH RELIGION.
THAT'S THE QUICKEST WAY TO
BEHIND PEOPLE.
IF THEY THINK YOU SHARE A COMMON
FAITH, THEY'LL IGNORE IT AND
THAT RELIGION IS EFFECTIVE
ALTRUISM.
THERE'S A LOTTED OF EFFECTIVE
ALTRUISTS.
IT'S A KIND OF RELIGIOUS
MOVEMENT AND IT'S POPULAR IN THE
TECH WORLD AND FINANCIAL WORLD.
THE IDEA IS YOU MAKE MONEY NOT
BECAUSE YOU'RE GREEDY, NOT
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A BOTTOMLESS
PIT INSIDE YOU OF GREED THAT
NEEDS FILLED.
BUT YOU WANT TO HELP OTHER
PEOPLE AND IN THE MOST EFFICIENT
WAY AND BENEFIT THE GREATEST
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE IN THE MOST
EFFICIENT WAY SO THAT MEANS
EFFECTS OF ALTRUISTS GET TO
UNDERPAY THEIR HOUSEKEEPERS AND
STIFF THE WATER ON THE TIP, BUT
THAT'S OKAY BECAUSE THEY'RE
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT AB
TRACTION TRAGEDIES LIKE GLOBAL
WARMING.
IF NOTHING ELSE, EFFECTIVE
ALTRUISTS GIVES YOU A COVER TO
LIVE TAX FREE IN SPLENDOR IN A
BEACH FRONT PAIR DICE AS SAM
BANKMAN-FRIED DID AND CONTINUES
TO DO TO THIS DAY.
STILL IN ALBANY IN THE BAHAMAS.
GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT SAM
BANKMAN-FRIED TALKED ABOUT
ALTRUISM AND ENJOYED A HIGH EXG
SCORE AND HIGHER THAN EXXON
GETTING YOUR AMBULANCE TO THE
HOSPITAL AND PLANE IN THE AIR TO
SEE YOUR KIDS AND HEATS YOUR
HOME.
SAM BANKMAN-FRIED WAS CONSIDERED
A MORAL LEADER RIPPING OFF
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
BUT NO ONE BENEFITED LONG TERM
FROM FTX'S COLLAPSE OR WILL
BENEFIT MORE THAN GOVERNMENT
REGULATORS AND THEY'RE POINTING
TO FTX AND DEMANDING MORE
CONTROL OVER CRYPTO CURRENCY AND
ULTIMATELY THE END OF THE CASH
ECONOMY.
WHY DO WE THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
DO THAT?
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALREADY WORKING
ON IT.
SEC COMMISSIONER HESTER PIERCE
SAID THIS WEEK THE GUYS OF FTX
COULD BE A CATALYST FOR MORE
REGULATION.
WHY SHOULD YOU WORRY ABOUT THAT.
WELL, AS WE SAW IN CANADA LAST
YEAR, CRYPTO IS A HUGE PROBLEM
FOR GOVERNMENTS.
GOVERNMENTS CAN'T CONTROL
IDEALLY CRYPTOCURRENCY AND CAN'T
FREEZE SOMEONE'S PERSONAL COLD
WALLET WITH CRYPTO IF YOU DON'T
LIKE WHAT THEY SAY.
WHAT DOES THIS HAVE TO DO WITH
THE COLLAPSE OF FTX.
IT TURNS OUT THAT SAM
BANKMAN-FRIED'S GIRLFRIEND
CAROLINE ELLISON HAS A LOT OF
CONNECTIONS TO REGULATORS AND
THE BIGGEST IN THIS COUNTRY.
HER FATHER GLENN IS AN MIT
PROFESSOR THAT WORKED AT THAT
UNIVERSITY THAT WORKED ALONGSIDE
GARY GENSLER THE HEAD OF SCC IN
CHARGE OF CRYPTOCURRENCY
REGULATION.
HE WORKED WITH GENSLER ON THE
TRADING COMMISSION AND NOW
GENSLER IS ABOUT TO GET A LOT
MORE POWER.
THIS THING SWELLS TO
UNSUSTAINABLE SIZE AND
INEVITABLY IMPLODES AND
COLLAPSES AND THAT COLLAPSE IS
USED FOR PRETEXT TO DO WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN PLANNING TO DO ALL
ALONG.
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T SHOCK YOU
THAT AFTER THE COLLAPSE, EVERY
MAJOR BANK IN THE COUNTRY
ANNOUNCE ADD NEW PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE NEW YORK FED TO
ESTABLISH A NEW DIGITAL
CURRENCY.
IF THEY HAVE CONTROL OF YOUR
MONEY AND DIGITAL AND CAN'T
STASH UNDER YOUR BED IF THEY
DON'T LIKE WHAT YOU SAY, THEY
CAN TURN IT OFF AND YOU'RE
IMPOVERISHED.
THIS WHO WILL THING IS A BIGGER
SCAM THAN IT SEEMS AND MADE
POSSIBLE BY POLITICAL SLOGAN
NEARING.
SAM BANKMAN-FRIED KNOWS THAT
WELL AND PUT IT IN THE MESSAGE
TO REPORT THE OTHER DAY FROM THE
HIDEOUT IN THE BAHAMAS AND WOKE
POSTURING IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
BUSINESS PLOY AND I FEEL BAD FOR
THOSE THAT GET FED BY IT BUT
THIS DUMB GAME THE WOKE
WESTERNERS PLAY AND WE'RE RIGHT
CHIVALROUS AND THEY LIKE US.
IF YOU SUSPECTED ALL THIS WAS A
SCAM, ALL THE MORAL POSTURING
AND LECTURES YOU GET ABOUT
THEY'RE GREAT AND YOU'RE BAD,
THIS WAS ALL A WAY TO BEHIND YOU